oui il y a eu des dysfonctionnements
c'est ce qu'a reconnu un gérald darmanin
lors de son audition par la commission
des lois du sénat le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a été interrogé pendant
un peu plus d'une heure a été confronté
en début d'audition au asie maj de
bulletins de vote brûlé par exemple en
haute savoie ou éparpillés sur la route
dans l'eure sur les raisons de ces
dysfonctionnements
gérald darmanin a rappelé le défi
logistique que présentait elle cette
double élection précisant que le pays
n'en avait pas à organiser depuis 1986
il a aussi évoqué un potentiel manque
est d'expérience de la part de l'un des
fournisseurs en charge de la
distribution à des professions de foi
prestataires qui se nomme adrexo gérald
darmanin qui a estimé il l'a rappelé
plusieurs fois un ca dysfonctionnements
ne sont pas les seuls responsables de
l'abstention record du premier tour de
ces élections régionales et
départementales
quant aux solutions envisagées le
ministre de l'intérieur a évoqué
plusieurs pistes je propose de l'écouter
je pense qu'il faudrait des dates
distribution pour telle ou telle
élection ils ont passé une semaine avant
qu'un jour vente faudrait ont décidé de
savoir quel meilleur moyen pour la
participation afin peut-être d'assurer
un moment de rattrapage par la société
ou par l'état si jamais on n'est pas
reçue la propagande premièrement cette
date n'existe pas donc on ne peut pas
l'imposer aux missionnaires du marché
quand je crois que ce qui ce qui serait
le plus ce qui serait le plus efficace
bien évidemment ce serait de pouvoir
considérer que lorsqu on distribue la
propagande électorale on puisse la
mettre à disposition aussi des électeurs
y compris le jour du vote je ne suis pas
certain monsieur le président et ce
suite à des autres ça fait près il
répond donc puisque je suis intéressé à
cette question dès ma nomination que
nous aurions pu changer grand chose vu
les décisions dictées par les mesures
sanitaires et dont chacun se rappelle à
l'époque la grande question qui se
posait pour la tenue de ces scrutins
et donc j'ai rappelé que beaucoup de nos
pays voisins avaient remporté ces
élections je dis pas certain que nous
aurions pu faire absolument mieux avec
les impositions de marché et les règles
sanitaires qui nous est imposé gérald
darmanin qui a aussi indiqué que les
deux prestataires
et leur maximum pour que ces
dysfonctionnements ne se reproduisent
pas lors du second tour du second tour
mais il a aussi prévenu un il est
évident que 100 % de la distribution de
la propagande électorale ne pourra être
assurée des explications qui était très
attendue par la commission à des lois
nous attendons beaucoup de vous ce matin
a par ailleurs indiqué le président de
la commission en début d'audition la
commission des lois qui devraient à
présent entendre les patrons de la poste
et d'adrexo sur ces différents à
dysfonctionnements donc qui ont entaché
le premier tour des élections
départementales et régionales